after the on tante victory in the First
World War Germany lost this territory
which notably included what's called the
Polish corridor this area was handed
over to the newly founded polish
Republic in order to grant Poland access
to the sea and thus control over its
international trade this corridor lacked
any major ports barring one which was
located in the city of Danzig known as
Gdansk in Polish the city in the
surrounding area was overwhelmingly
German and so it wasn't directly awarded
to Poland but instead was made an
independent state but of course given
its geopolitical position it's special
status and the conflict surrounding it
the question should be asked how free
was the free city of Danzig well there
were many ways in which it acted as any
other free nation could it had its own
currency the Danzig golden and for the
most part it could set its own fiscal
policy although you should know that
Danzig nearly always struggled
financially the free city had its own
Parliament the Volk star which was
elected by any one man a woman over the
age of 20 it issued its own passports
and his citizens were neither Germans
nor poles but was simply danziger's the
dancy constitution made sure that all
people who lived in the city were to be
treated equal in all respects but German
Polish M&T remained high throughout the
period of the Free Cities existence part
of this was of course due to the war but
also that throughout the other areas of
Germany which were incorporated into
Poland the Germans who remained there
faced major discrimination so since
Danzig was the largest port in the
Polish corridor the majority of Polish
exports traveled through it
Poland wanted to maintain trade
independence and so the League of
Nations gave Poland the right to
determine what went in and out of the
port and it was Poland not Danzig that
could set tariffs on goods now the free
city did get a proportion of this income
or when polish german relations soured a
trade war per account thus the
danziger's who wanted to join germany
were forced to implement tariffs against
it which really soured the relations
between itself and Poland Danzig didn't
have its own military which meant that
when Poland decided to send over 150
troops there to make a point to the
newly elected German Chancellor the
people could do nothing about it
these tensions combined with the desire
to be reunited with Germany make it
unsurprising that throughout the 1930s
the people of Danzig voted the Nazi
Party into power there the free city of
Danzig come to an end after the German
invasion of Poland where it was brought
back into Germany and after the
conclusion of the Second World War it
was made a permanent part of Poland the
city was supposed to be a sovereign
independent state but this frankly
couldn't happen
whilst Poland needed access to
international overseas trade the city
could never
truly be free and whilst the people of
the city were overwhelmingly German and
wish to remain so it had to be free
this combined with Germany proper
wanting it back meant the conflict was
always going to erupt over the city's
future I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with extra
thanks to my patrons that you see on
screen now and a special thanks to James
Bissonnette David archaeologist zarqa
flash party boy Co Rob Waterhouse Yashar
Enderman Chris wicker Myles Bailey Brent
guard Michael Reynolds Gustav Swann tune
Ric onion duck
Maggie packs Kowski Winston K word for
Celia vadas Anthony Beckett Adam Harvey
Ike Skye Chappell and the amusement park
Ives